[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
guten abend als wir im heute journal
gestern über die ukrainischen
kernkraftwerke berichteten hielten wir
das noch für eine relativ theoretische
gefahr letzte nacht nur stunden später
wurde das plötzlich sehr real ein brand
auf dem gelände des größten
kernkraftwerks europas nach heftigem
beschuss ist das der planmäßige
kriegsverlauf von dem wladimir putin
sprach
die bilder von dem akw brand sind nicht
die einzigen die einen zutiefst
erschüttern
und chef einer großstadt im norden der
ukraine wurden wohngebiete bombardiert
so sieht das aus wenn putin sein
nachbarland
entmilitarisiert
sie haben gesehen dass wir die am boden
liegenden menschen überblendet haben
nicht nur weil der anblick unerträglich
ist sondern auch weil es den opfern ihre
letzte hürde nehmen würde aber dieses
grauen ist die realität dieses krieges
es ist das was die ukraine im moment
erleben jeden tag
christian von rechenberg hat
zusammengestellt was sich seit letzter
nacht ereignet hat
der tag beginnt mit diesen bildern rund
um das atomkraftwerk subotic tobt ein
gefecht ob die reaktoren gezielt unter
feuer genommen werden ist unklar
beschädigt wird zum glück nur ein
ausbildungs gebäude der ukrainische
präsident wendet sich am morgen an das
russische volk
seit euro-einführung dass ihr leben
leben in einer welt die nicht radioaktiv
verseucht ist strahlung macht auch vor
russen nicht halt
panzer und soldaten in bewegung zeigt
das russische staatsfernsehen
doch der kilometerlange militärkonvoi
der sich seit tagen auf kiew zubewegt
hat offenbar probleme heißt es von
amerikanischer seite er sei ins stocken
geraten angeblich unter beschuss 15
kilometer von kiew wo es heute wieder
explosionen gab wieder luft annahme muss
sich zivilisten und soldaten
auf den straßen kampf vorbereiten
niemals aufgeben aber wir brauchen hier
weil wir gern wir nicht sich selbst wie
gern für alle demokratische welt
überall ruft die ukraine um helfer
überall der gleiche schrecken jeremy 200
kilometer entfernt von kiew
borodjanka gestern massiv angegriffen
bilder aus der apokalypse auch aus aktiv
im nordosten die zweitgrößte stadt der
ukraine sendet botschaften
werden nicht aufgeben wir bleiben wir in
unserem land in unserer stadt so lange
es dauert
der krieg wird lange dauern lässt putin
sein land heute wissen mittlerweile ist
facebook in russland blockiert sowie
weitere medien das parlament will ich
zudem ein gesetz das angebliche fake
news über die armee unter strafe stellt
und putin über bringt seinen nachbarn
angebot schafft
er habe ihm gegenüber keine bösen
absichten
ich würde ihnen raten die situation
nicht zuzuspitzen keine einschränkungen
einzuführen
worte die niemanden beruhigen in lemberg
im westen der ukraine bringen sie ihre
wertvollsten kunstschätze in sicherheit
während nicht weit entfernt der chef der
ukrainischen verhandler vor die presse
tritt
unser präsident wird ganz sicher ich
wiederhole ganz sicher keine
zugeständnisse machen die das
ukrainische volk in seinem kampf für
freiheit und die unverletzlichkeit
unseres staatsgebiets demütigen könnten
und immer mehr menschen fliehen aus der
ukraine laut un sollen es knapp 1,2
millionen sein
kiew verbunden sind wir mit professor
metro juba er ist mediziner war zuletzt
eigentlich in der medizinischen
universität als dozent für anästhesie
und intensivmedizin tätig aber das jetzt
aber wieder auf station im stadt
klinikum von kiew von dort aus zu helfen
guten abend herr professor 7
guten abend wie ist ihre situation in
der klinik
im moment ist es so dass unser
krankenhaus in der nähe des
stadtzentrums gelegen ist
wir sind ein bisschen näher an der
westgrenze von kiew
und da gibt es große kämpfe mit den
russen im moment
wir haben einige patienten aus kiel
weil einige gruppen von feinden in kiew
sind
[Musik]
unsere selbstverteidigungskräfte
bekämpfen die russischen kräfte und da
bekommen wir eben patienten und da gibt
es auch noch
patienten aus dem zentrum von kiew aber
es ist sehr schwierig die patienten zu
transportieren
das liegt einfach an der kriegssituation
also wir arbeiten
dieses wenn es luftalarm gibt denen sie
dann mit den patienten soweit die
transportfähig sind in einen keller oder
wie schützen sie sich
ja in den letzten tag habe praktisch
jede stunde einen bombenalarm
wir haben eine intensivstation bei uns
und wir können unsere patienten da nicht
einfach alleine lassen
und die meisten unserer leute sind unten
im keller
aber wir können die intensivpatienten
jetzt nicht allein lassen das heißt wir
beiden bei denen
einige von uns bleiben da in der auf der
station auf der intensivstation
worauf bereiten sie sich dann in den
nächsten tagen vor es gibt ja die
vermutung dass kiew eingekesselt wird
ja das ist natürlich ein großes problem
[Musik]
versuchen jetzt praktisch unsere stadt
einzukesseln
und dann ist es natürlich sehr schwierig
sich fortzubewegen nicht nur aus der app
heraus sondern auch in kiew ist es
schwierig für die bürger sich zu bewegen
gerade jetzt im moment während dieser
tage wo die russen uns praktisch
umzingeln wollen aber wir hoffen dass es
dann grüne korridore gibt
in der nähe unseres krankenhauses
da finden die größten
kampfhandlungen ungefähr 10 15 kilometer
entfernt von unserem krankenhaus statt
[Musik]
und wir warten jetzt auf neuigkeiten aus
der richtung wir hoffen dass die russen
da einen grünen korridor einsetzen um
uns damit wir unsere
verletzten
rausbringen können evakuieren können
nicht nur die kriegsverletzten auch die
normale patienten denn wir haben jetzt
natürlich große probleme hier in der
stadt kiew
es war eine sehr schöne stadt marl aber
jetzt moment ist alles zerstört
[Musik]
also wir haben jetzt ganz viele
verletzte die zu uns kommen und
zwar durch weiß gibt es schon einige
krankenhäuser
die einfach keine kapazitäten mehr für
die patienten die kam dann zu und wir
haben die dann behandelt
wir wünschen das beste für sie und ihre
patienten vielen herzlichen dank dass
sie sich die zeit genommen haben uns zu
berichten wie es bei ihnen steht und wie
es ihnen geht
denkt ihr früher danke ihnen für ihre
unterstützung
wir brauchen diese unterstützung und wir
fühlen uns stark wenn wir das gefühl
haben dass europa und unterstützt
unterstützt das macht uns stärker danke
das gespräch haben wir aufgezeichnet zu
einer zeit als professor die uhr gerade
die möglichkeit dazu hatte
bundeskanzler scholz ist noch in der
nacht vom ukrainischen präsidenten sie
lenski angerufen wurden der ihn über den
brand an dem kernkraftwerk informiert
welche potenziellen gefahren von solchen
ereignissen ausgehen ist offensichtlich
cdu chef friedrich merz sagte sogar wenn
es gezielte angriffe auf atomkraftwerke
gebe und damit auch wir unmittelbar
bedroht würden müsste die nato darüber
nachdenken ob das nicht doch auch ein
angriff auf das eigene territorium sein
nähere informationen zu den betroffenen
kernkraftwerken borussia und was
atomexperten dazu sagen hat jetzt kamera
safari
die anlage des größten kernkraftwerkes
in europa unter beschuss ein feuerball
über dem atomkraftwerk sapori skier im
südosten der ukraine
putins truppen rücken vor kurz darauf
lodern flammen aus einem gebäude
verzweifelter hilferuf des kraftwerks
sprechers in der nacht
streitkräfte der russischen föderation
schießen auf das kraftwerk sa borussia
es besteht die gefahr einer nuklearen
bedrohung des größten atomkraftwerks in
europa du glück im unglück nur ein
schulungscenter wird getroffen das feuer
ist inzwischen gelöscht zwei wachmänner
werden verletzt reaktorblöcke und
kritische systeme sind nicht betroffen
die internationale atomenergiebehörde
gibt vorerst
das wichtigste ist alle
sicherheitssysteme der sechs reaktoren
im kernkraftwerk wurde nicht
beeinträchtigt und
es wurde auch kein radioaktives material
freigesetzt
das ukrainische kernkraftwerks après ski
ist strategisch wichtig seine sechs
druckwasserreaktoren
produzieren mehr als ein fünftel des
ukrainischen stroms hier bildete anlage
von 2016 nach dem beschuss läuft nur
noch einer der blöcke das hat
konsequenzen wissen experten einerseits
hat die ukraine weniger strom zur
verfügung für industrieanlagen und
haushalte aber man braucht natürlich
auch strom für das kraftwerk auch für
abgeschaltete reaktoren braucht man hohe
strom und kühlleistung weil durch die
nachzerfallswärme durch den radioaktiven
zerfall dass ich nicht stoppen lässt
kann noch ein abgeschaltete reaktor sich
überhitzen und in eine kernschmelze und
in große freisetzungen kommen das
kernkraftwerk soll sich inzwischen in
russischer hand befinden analysten
sprechen von ukrainischer sabotage dem
widerspricht präsident seelands
kein anderer staat aus russland hat
jemals ein atomkraftwerk geschossen zum
ersten mal in unserer geschichte in der
geschichte der menschheit betreibt ein
terroristischer staat nuklear terror in
einer dringlichkeitssitzung im un
sicherheitsrat machen die usa heute
russland für den angriff verantwortlich
durch die gnade gottes ist die welt
letzten acht nur knapp einer nuklearen
katastrophe entgangen wir alle haben die
luft angehalten als er die schrecklichen
ereignisse mit ansehen mussten
eine nukleare katastrophe in sapporo sie
sie hätte uns alle getroffen
reporterin in der ukraine ist uns
zugeschaltet katrin eigendorf ist im
westen des landes unterwegs sind de
mortel mit ski katrin wie haben die
menschen in der ukraine so weit wir das
beobachten und erfahren konnte es auf
diese nachricht von diesem brand in dem
atomkraftwerk reagiert
die menschen hier haben erstaunlich
gelassen darauf reagiert man muss sich
vorstellen das
kraftwerk saccharose ist von hier nur
600 kilometer entfernt und nur 140
kilometer von dem ort entfernt befindet
sich ein weiteres kernkraftwerk
es hat ihr heute den ganzen tag in der
stadt auch durchsagen gegeben über
megafon wo die lage beschrieben wurde
aber alle leute mit denen ich gesprochen
habe haben gesagt wir haben eigentlich
moment ganz andere sorgen also wir sind
jetzt hier nicht in panik für uns ist ja
mal die bedrohung am boden die soldaten
die hier reingehen die panzer die hier
reinkommen viel konkreter das ist das
bild was ich hier so gewinnen konnte und
mein eindruck ist dass dieser angriff
auf saccharose ja vor allem auch darauf
zielt den westen zu verunsichern denn
diese große welle der sympathie die
unterstützung für das ukrainische volk
und seinen widerstand das besorgt
natürlich putin und im prinzip denke ich
stecke dahinter auch die strategie diese
sympathie in angst umzuwandeln und
darauf damit dieser strategie hat er ja
sicherlich auch erfolg wie man den
nachrichten entnehmen kann allerdings
die ukrainische regierung hat heute
nochmal in levi auf einer
pressekonferenz und auch in kiew ganz
deutlich gemacht dass die ukraine hier
vor einer riesenkatastrophe steht wenn
putin weiter atomkraftwerke angreifen
sollte und die wichtigste forderung der
ukraine ist dass sie sagen im prinzip
muss jetzt der luftraum über der ukraine
gesperrt werden denn sonst so hat es ein
berater des präsidenten gesagt wird die
ukraine über kurz oder lang von der
landkarte weggefegt
katrin danke für diese eindrücke und
einschätzungen aus der ukraine
hilflos bei alldem zuzusehen empfinden
menschen weltweit als furchtbar die
bereitschaft geflüchteten zu helfen ist
hoch und viele legen sich ein anti
kriegs protesten der russische
oppositionelle alexej nawalny hat aus
dem gefängnis heraus dazu aufgerufen an
diesem sonntag um 14 uhr auf den
zentralen plätzen aller städte russlands
und der ganzen welt gegen den krieg zu
demonstrieren
den hilferufen und hoffnungen der
ukraine dass der westen militärisch
eingreift erteilte nato-generalsekretärs
dalton burg heute erneut eine absage
anna krüger berichtet er beging wir
flehen sie ein bitte beschützen sie
unseren himmel
der ruf ist eigentlich laut genug allein
es fehlt der wille auf der anderen
straßenseite
nato-hauptquartier
familienfoto es ist der tag an dem sich
außen minister und ministerinnen des
westens zweimal treffen und die ukraine
2 mal enttäuschen der amtskollege aus
kiew meldet sich per video
wir sind bereit zum kampf wir kämpfen
weiter aber hilft uns wenn nicht dann
tragt ihr einen teil der verantwortung
für die leben und das leiden der
ukrainischen bevölkerung
doch sein ruf nach einer flugverbotszone
einer no fly zone zumindest über
atomaren anlagen verheilt selbst die
wohl gesonnen sind nicht gewählt und
nicht zustand wärs muss die no fly zone
überall von der uno entschieden werden
wir sind ja realisten und dann das
zweite wer würde das dann auch
kontrollieren
bilder eines russischen tank manövers
gestern an der grenze zum nato mitglied
norwegen nato-jets mussten die russen
abfangen so glimpflich so friedlich
blieb es wohl kaum bei einem kontakt
über der ukraine
ich bin fest überzeugt wenn die nato
direkt in den konflikt verwickelt wird
dann wird es mehr menschliches leid
geben
am nachmittag fast derselbe kreis im
anderen rahmen die eu hat schon drei
pakete mit sanktionen fein abgestimmt
mit und dafür hoch gelobt vom gast aus
den usa doch deutschland gibt sich nicht
zufrieden jetzt geht es darum dass alle
sanktionsmaßnahmen auch wirken das
heißen dass die lücken die wir sehen
können dass zb finanzflüsse jetzt
umgangen werden und auf anderen kanälen
durchgeführt werden dass wir diese
schließen weniger eifer hat deutschland
wenn es darum geht sanktionen auf mehr
privatbanken zu erweitern polen hatte
das gefordert
aber es galt länder wieder abgelehnt
haben weil sie in so großer abhängigkeit
von russischem gas stuhl
gemeint ist wohl auch sie aus sicht von
deutschland müssen die sanktionen nun
erst mal wirken aus sicht der ukraine
könnte es dann zu spät sein
auch die bundesregierung hat angst vor
einer eskalation bei der sich am ende
noch russland und die nato gegenüber
stehen bundeskanzler scholz warnte vor
einer ausweitung des krieges außerdem
hat er heute mit putin telefoniert und
zu einer waffenruhe aufgefordert
anscheinend mit ähnlichem erfolg in
anführungszeichen die gestern emanuel
makro man habe mit moskau seine
unterschiedlichen standpunkte
ausgetauscht hieß es danach in berlin zu
den vielen auswirkungen dieses krieges
gehört ja auch dass die neuaufstellung
der bundeswehr vorangetrieben wird olaf
scholz besuchte heute das
einsatzführungskommando
bei potsdam
davon berichtet ines trams
sein besuch im einsatzführungskommando
sei lange geplant gewesen betont kanzler
scholz als wolle er nicht unnötig angst
schüren der krieg nicht der anlass
seines besuchs wohl aber anlass für 100
milliarden euro mehr für die bundeswehr
es ist gut dass ich bei dieser
gelegenheit auch darauf verweisen konnte
das nun aus aktuellem anlass zwar aber
richtigerweise wir die entscheidung
getroffen haben die bundeswehr mit
vielen zusätzlichen mitteln für ihre
ausrüstung zu versehen
die bundeswehr ein sanierungsfall es
muss ein nachfolger für den veralteten
tornado her auch ein neuer
transporthubschrauber für 20 milliarden
euro allein muss munition aufgestockt
werden es gilt zurück zur bündnis und
landesverteidigung zurück zu groß
verbänden die sofort startklar sind wir
können nicht aus dem stand heraus in den
einsatz wir sind nur noch geplant
einsatzfähig wie jetzt geplant an der
nato nordost flanke mit blick auf die
künftigen bedrohungen muss es aber auch
fingerschnipp gehen das heißt innerhalb
weniger tagen und wochen müssen verbände
geschlossen beübt aus sich heraus
einsatz und führungsfähigkeit den weg
geschickt werden können doch geld allein
löst nicht alles das beschaffungsamt der
bundeswehr in koblenz oftmals
langwierige verfahren sollen nun
verkürzt werden durch ein vereinfachtes
vergaberecht weniger ausschreibungen und
weniger sonderanfertigungen wenn wir zum
beispiel eine neue fregatte wollen dann
wird die bis zur letzten schraube wird
das aufgeschrieben wie das auszusehen
hat wir reden leider immer von deutschen
lösungen das heißt das beschaffungsamt
neigt dazu immer individuelle lösungen
auf den tisch zu legen das ist nicht
nötig vieles was die bundeswehr bislang
bestellte kam zu spät fehlerhaft oder
teurer von
350 puma schützenpanzern sind derzeit
nur 40 verwendungsfähig nun soll alles
schlichter und schneller werden
natürlich muss auch die industrie immer
sich selber prüfen und keiner ist frei
von fehlern aber es ist insgesamt ein
zeichen dafür dass der gesamte prozess
viel zu viel komplexitäten hat spd und
grüne unterstützen die idee eines
sondervermögens für die bundeswehr wenn
auch unter bauchschmerzen auch die union
die größte oppositionspartei ziert sich
nur ein bisschen es geht darum dass wir
bei der beschaffung der waffensysteme
als cdu und csu mitsprechen können die
verwendung des geldes ist das
entscheidende mit uns gemeinsam zu
erledigen dann sind wir auch dabei wenn
es darum geht das geld zu beschaffen
scholz an der gedenkstätte für die
soldaten die im einsatz ihr leben
verloren die bundeswehr will er
aufrüsten putins brutalität so sagt er
lässt ihm keine andere wahl
nachher im heute-journal update gibt es
noch ein gespräch mit der vorsitzenden
des verteidigungsausschusses im
bundestag marie agnes strack zimmermann
und jetzt macht heinz wolf weiter mit
weiteren nachrichten zum ukraine krieg
und anderen themen die zahl der in
deutschland ankommenden
kriegsflüchtlinge aus der ukraine steigt
bis zum mittag stellte die bundespolizei
die ankunft von knapp 19.000 menschen
fest die tatsächliche anzahl soll jedoch
höher liegen da die einreise nach
deutschland nicht zentral erfasst werden
ein großer teil der flüchtenden kommt in
berlin an am hauptbahnhof haben helfer
ein versorgungszentrum eingerichtet in
dem die geflüchteten etwa mit essen
trinken und unterkünften versorgt werden
und wenn sie den menschen in der ukraine
und jenen auf der flucht helfen wollen
können sie spenden zum beispiel beim
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine bahn.de
65 104 106 100 104 106 100 alle infos
auch unter spenden punkt zdf de oder im
zdf text auf seite 8 190
neben all dem menschlichen leid hat der
krieg auch auswirkungen auf die
wirtschaft an der frankfurter börse hat
dass sina mainitz im blick wie es dort
die einschätzung für die europäischen
börsen war es die schlimmste woche seit
beginn der korona pandemie vor dem
wochenende ist die unsicherheit enorm
groß und sie führt zum ausverkauf am
aktienmarkt seit kriegsbeginn verliert
der dax 11 prozent und hält sich heute
abend nur noch mühevoll oberhalb der 13
tausendermarke die aktienkurse fallen
während die rohstoffpreise unaufhaltsam
steigen sei es nun öl aluminium gold
oder erdgas letzteres ist so teuer wie
noch nie noch im vergangenen dezember
zahlte man 148 euro pro megawattstunde
heute waren es knapp 214 euro nicht nur
energie auch ernährung wird teurer jedes
dritte büschel weizen das auf der welt
gehandelt wird stammt entweder aus
russland oder der ukraine
der weizenpreis legt binnen einer woche
über 40 prozent zu in ärmeren ländern
drohen hungersnöte normalerweise haben
geopolitische spannungen nur einen
vorübergehenden einfluss auf die
rohstoff und aktienmärkte dieses mal
könnte es anders sein der meine vielen
dank
der us elektroautobauer tesla hat rund
zwei jahre nach baustart grünes licht
für seine fabrik bei berlin bekommen das
land brandenburg genehmigte die giga
factory in grünheide unter auflagen
diese wolle tesla innerhalb von zwei
wochen abarbeiten unter anderem zum
schutz des wassers das projekt gilt als
eines der wichtigsten industrie-
vorhaben in ostdeutschland dort sollen
rund 12.000 beschäftigte bis zu 500.000
autos pro jahr produzieren
das bundesgesundheitsministerium sieht
weiterhin noch keine flächendeckende
entspannung des corona
infektionsgeschehen es in deutschland
man habe es insgesamt nach wie vor mit
einer recht hohen inzidenz zu tun das
robert koch institut registrierte
neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
6850 mehr als vor einer woche 291
todesfälle kamen innerhalb eines tages
hinzu die sieben tage incidents erhöht
sich auf
1.196 4
schon bei den olympischen spielen waren
die begleitumstände in peking jahr
unglücklich und jetzt auch noch krieg in
europa für die paralympics ein denkbar
trauriger hintergrund
wenigstens wird man dort keine
wettbewerbe zwischen ukrainischen und
russischen athleten sehen müssen von der
eröffnung berichtet christian hofft
dass sie bei diesen paralympics
überhaupt dabei sein können grenze an
ein wunder sagen die ukrainischen
athleten ein teil des teams flow direkt
aus dem kriegsgebiet tage lang waren sie
unterwegs viele von ihnen sorgen sich um
ihre familien ist not wir sind nicht
hier um für großartige ergebnisse zu
kämpfen wir kämpfen für frieden für alle
für irland und für andere länder
die geballte faust wie zum trotz in den
himmel gereckt die ukraine ist noch da
so die botschaft die eröffnungsfeier vom
krieg überschattet der olympische friede
durch russlands präsident gebrochen und
vom ausrichter der spiele zumindest
toleriert vielleicht sogar mit wissen
von präsident lee begonnen frieden in
einer gemeinsamen zukunft heißt die
musik zu der sie umjubelt das stadion
betritt
erst spät entschloss sich das
paralympische komitee russland und
belarus auszuschließen jetzt ein aufruf
zum frieden
als der chef einer organisation die
inklusion ihren kernen tvo vielfalt
gefeiert und unterschiede umarmt werden
bin ich entsetzt darüber was gerade in
der welt passieren das 21 jahrhundert
ist eine zeit des dialogs und für
diplomatie nicht für krieg und hass
ein emotionaler appell für diplomatie
und vor allem für
frieden chinas staatsmedien übersetzen
parsons appell in ihrer live übertragung
nicht sondern nur sein lob der gut
vorbereiteten spiele china inszeniert
eine bunte eröffnungsfeier gestaltet von
tänzern und sängern mit und ohne
behinderungen eine scheinbar heile welt
in einem land in dem das leistungs
diktat herrscht und menschen mit
behinderungen lange keinen platz hatten
bis heute ist china von wirklicher
inklusion weit entfernt
deutschland ist mit 17 athleten in
peking und die setzen ein zeichen ihrer
ausgestreckten arme fort das peace
symbol schwierig sich jetzt auf das
wesentliche einer sportveranstaltung zu
konzentrieren während jetzt da die post
abgeht und
[Applaus]
vielfalt und verständigung sind ideen
der paralympics im schatten des ukraine
krieges haben sie derzeit einen
schlechten stand
das was im heute journal über alle
aktuellen entwicklungen halten wir sie
natürlich weiter online auf dem
laufenden auf zdf heute um 00 35 gibt's
dann unser heute schon ein update mit
christopher wehrmann und uns morgen
wieder nach wiedersehen wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend heute nacht ist es hier im
osten stärker bewölkt im westen dagegen
klar und die temperaturen sinken auf
werte zwischen null grad auf rügen und
minus 10 grad am alpenrand
morgen bleibt es kalt besonders in der
osthälfte da steigen die temperaturen
nicht über zwei bis fünf grad hinaus im
westen klettern sie immerhin auf fünf
bis zehn grad im osten gibt es morgen
dichtere wolkenfelder nebel und
hochnebel sollten sich dann aber bis zum
mittag meist aufgelöst haben und im
westen scheint die sonne strahlt an
diesem wetter ändert sich wenig ruhiges
wetter also bei uns katastrophale
überschwemmungen im südosten australiens
weite teile der bundesstaaten queensland
und new south wales stehen unter wasser
schon letztes jahr gab es jahrhundert
fluten und nun schiebt das klimaphänomen
la niña das zweite jahr in folge dass
warmes pazifikwasser an die ostküste
warme feuchte luft steigt auf die
globale temperaturerhöhung beschleunigt
diesen prozess perfekte bedingungen für
sehr langsam ziehende nahezu ortsfest
große tief solch ein tief saugt sich
voll mit wasser und schüttet tage lang
hunderte liter regen über eine sehr
große region aus jetzt am wochenende
lassen die regenfälle etwas nach und
drohen sich nächste woche schon wieder
zu intensivieren
auf wiedersehen